بلغت قيمه السوق العملات المشفره بحلول
نهايه عام 2021 نحو ثلاثه تريليونات دولار
مقارنه ب 250 مليون في مطلع عام 2020 لكن
هذا الصعود الصاروخي تبعه سقوط مدول يصل
الى واحد فاصله ثلاثه تريليون دولار في
الوقت الحالي مجله ايكونوميست ارجعت
انحدار صناعه العملات المشفره الى تدني
ثقه الراي العام خصوصا معا انهيار بورصه
العملات المشفره
الماضي صناعه العملات المشفره تشهد حاله
استقطاب كبيره البعض يرى ان الوعود بانها
ستحدث ثوره في القطاع المالي قد تحطمت لكن
لا يزال هناك امل في تلك الصناعه اذ زاد
سعر عمله بيتكوين بنسبه 70% تقريبا هذا
العام شملت زياده في عقاب انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي اما بنك فقال الشهر الماضي
ان بيتكوين قد تصل الى 100 الف دولار
بحلول نهايه عام 20 24 وان يطلق عليه
الشتاء العملات المشفره انتهى تقول ميسي
ان العملات المشفره تكسب ارضا في الدول
الضعيفه التي تعاني من تضخم وضعف العمله
مثل الارجنتين ونيجيريا في الخامس من
يناير كان اعلن المنظمون الامريكيون
وبينهم الاحتياطي الفيدرالي ان الاصول
المشفره على الشبكات اللامركزيه ليس تحت
سيطره سلطه مركزيه وتتعارض مع الممارسات
البنكيه بطبيعه الحال لكن هنا يبرز سؤال
الاهم ما الذي سيميز العملات المشفره لو
تم تطبيق الاجراءات المنظمه للشركات
الماليه العاديه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات